one thing he's gonna have to deal with
miles this popped late last night
the lawsuit was filed late last night i
got a copy of it earlier today we have a
full breakdown of profootballtalk.com a
sexual assault lawsuit involving
a massage that desean watson got
and he found this masseuse on instagram
exchanged a few messages with her went
to her house and the allegation from her
this is her allegation in the complaint
is that he
wanted more than a massage and
eventually there was
a a a a a an assault
a sexual assault not not a rape or
anything like that but
you can read it all on pft i don't want
to get into all the graphic details
but um it's something as i said today on
pft live that desean watson is going to
have to deal with
a tweet a statement a press release
that's not going to make it go away once
you activate the legal process
there are steps that are taken there are
documents
that are filed there are court dates
that are set
you don't just show up like joe pesci
and my cousin vinnie on the day of the
arraignment different context criminal
trial
and say we want to fast forward to a
dismissal
you have to go through the process he'll
have to answer
the complaint he'll have to submit at
some point to testimony under oath
they'll have to provide
text messages there's reference to text
messages that were exchanged between
the plaintiff who has gone with a
pseudonym to protect her identity
and desean watson you develop the case
and then at some point
the case potentially goes to trial
unless it's settled and
there was an effort to settle up
beforehand it didn't work and now this
is something that watson's going to have
to deal with and i heard from a gm today
who said how can you trade for deshaun
watson
when you have this cloud that's hanging
out there well one way you do it is you
put your own lawyers and security people
to work miles to get to the bottom of it
as quickly as possible and you make your
assessment
that's happened before that's not
unprecedented and and uh if you're
comfortable with the guy with the story
he's telling and that you believe it's
not going to become a major issue for
you at some point
you still proceed with the trade for
deshaun watson well
it's not just that it's happened before
it happens every single year
these teams do this with draft prospects
all the time
because there are different things that
come up whether it's you know an assault
charge because
uh a guy was you know trying to protect
his girlfriend
and the girlfriend was being harassed by
somebody and that ended up with an
assault charge and then you say okay
well i feel comfortable drafting this
guy
because i know what he was doing and i
know he was protecting his girlfriend
whether
it was maybe a marijuana charge that you
know the guy was caught
with a couple of grams of pot and then
you do you feel comfortable
dealing with that particular player
these things happen all the time
and nfl teams have a lot of people
who are able to investigate different
things
so that they feel comfortable with the
background of a player
in order to draft them and essentially
give them a lot of money
and decide that they want this player
representing them in their franchise so
i i think that yeah there are ways that
teams could become comfortable
with training for deshaun watson if if
they decide that they want to
investigate this particular issue
that has now come up for him it's it's
certainly possible
that a team can become comfortable doing
that i think and miles this is another
reason for the texans to set
basically the start of the draft as the
deadline because then it gives
everyone five six weeks to come to the
conclusion
that they're comfortable with this now
look if he's
guilty of what he's been accused of
doing and ultimately what will happen is
if there is a trial
it will be testimony from the masseuse
testimony from deshaun watson
who do you believe do you believe her do
you believe him
the standard is low in a civil case
proof beyond a reasonable doubt doesn't
have to
no no i'm sorry that that's the criminal
standard in a civil case it's
preponderance of the evidence it's i
it's first time i've ever gotten that
wrong i went to law school 30 years ago
i've been
i've known those standards for so long i
got them screwed up but preponderance to
the evidence 5149
it doesn't take much we were talking
about scales earlier all you have to do
is tip it a little bit in favor of one
or the other
and that's the outcome and and the
the challenge is going to be to the
extent there is objective
evidence in the communications
in the instagram ad that he responded to
the direct messages that would have been
sent the text messages that were sent
there's an allegation
in the complaint that he apologized via
text well what did the apology say
the document didn't attach any of that
stuff
those are all things are going to be
relevant to a jury of impartial
supposedly citizens the lawyer's job
on both sides is to make sure it's a
fair and impartial jury and they're
going to look at that and they're going
to make a decision and
and if he's found to have been
responsible civilly
then the question is what's the league
do because i personally think the
league's not going to intervene in this
even though they have the power to do it
miles
but just like with antonio brown's
pending charge of
sexual assault and rape in a civil
setting the league's
hey we investigated we don't know what
to do we're going to wait and see what
happens because what the league i think
doesn't want to do is say
it's fine no punishment and then there's
some major verdict
that screams out the guy did it i think
that
that what we can expect the league to do
here and they officially said no comment
but i think common sense would suggest
they probably won't do much of anything
they'll just monitor and they'll wait
and see
and if there is a verdict at some point
then
then you take action if needed and
uh i know desean watson scoffed at the
idea of a six-figure settlement
and i don't know whether that's a
hundred thousand or nine hundred ninety
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
but for what it's going to cost him to
hire a lawyer
and for the cloud it's gonna put over
him in the short term
and long term and the potential
depending upon how the dominoes fall
that he could be disciplined by the
league at some point it's money well
spent
once you accept just like the texans had
to accept
their situation desean watson's got to
work through anger denial bargaining
depression and accept
that the best way out of this situation
for him
is to figure out the right check to
write
to make this a business transaction and
clear it away
and again that even if he didn't do it
and this is one of the realities of
having to manage these kinds of risks
in a litigation setting even if he
didn't do it there's value
in not having to deal with this whole
process and worry
that things go haywire at trial and you
end up with an adverse verdict
yeah and that's why you know these
records they get sealed right
there there's all kinds of processes
where
when you sign something when there is a
settlement these things become secret
so that's exactly why they happen so
basically you are
able to say all right i am signing a
check
and i want to just use the saying make
this go away
but because that feels crass to me
especially when we're dealing with
something like sexual assault but
an effect that's kind of what you're
trying to do
because you're trying to say i want this
process to
end how do i end this process in
the best way possible for me and like
you said even if he did not do it
or if he did that could be
the the most expedient solution for him
to put this issue this particular
um this lawsuit behind him
and and i want to be clear on this and
i'm glad you made that point
this isn't a commentary on the
seriousness of the allegations
obviously if he actually did it it's a
different analysis altogether
but even if he knows in his heart he
didn't do it
and he knows that it's false and it's
fabricated and it's a money grab
even if it's all those things it's a
business transaction and you have to ask
yourself
is it worth dealing with this over the
next 18 months to two years
is it worth having this potentially
derail
my effort to get out of houston is it
worth all the money i'm gonna spend
one hour at a time on the lawyer who'll
be representing me in this case with no
guarantee
that i'm going to be able to convince a
jury of the truth
that i didn't do anything wrong that's
the mountain that you're staring at
when you've been sued if you truly are
innocent if you're guilty
he deserves everything he's going to get
through this process
whether he settles it or not if he's
innocent there's still
a good argument to be made to finding a
way as a business transaction
to remove this from his overall plate of
worries in his life
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports